hello there I'm Gavin done with a slow
mo guys as you can see today I've got
myself a drill and a condom what we're
gonna do is fill a condom for the water
and food coloring attach it to a drill
bit and then spin the drill up to much
high basically what's going to happen is
is that the drill is going to be
spinning the condom I'll pop it the
water inside will be spinning and
centrifugal force will cause the water
to spin out flat into like a disc and as
it falls the air will rise up through
the war making cool bubbles and I'm
going to track that with a phantom sound
effects it's gonna be like mmm and then
Shh it's how the fit yeah like it take
that you'll need it
oh these are not a good size I don't
know yeah you don't want to do that too
many of our videos of all condoms just
the right mouth enough no your foot
oh this Pepsi oh that's good
looks like a scientific like looks like
a big bloody cut flask looks good
pop oh all right yeah it's covered in
blood Oh crazy fish like a starfish
spread it out is it yeah that's what we
want
oh that already looks awesome there we
go look at that Oh wicked it is
attachment perfect globe it to a disc
that's amazing
that'll be underneath of it because it's
slow motion right it literally looks
like it's just flat like it just a ball
that just goes flat like that yeah for
no reason doesn't you can't see that
it's spinning this is a unique set of
skills
it's just I'm quite good at tying
condoms to drills alright we've got no
damn crew so a man in both the Phantoms
yeah
laughter I was about to pop it and I'll
let you go towards it and poof I don't
know if I got that
oh I got some bubbles there that's all
good
you see I didn't track it because I
wasn't ready as for I was waiting for
your the night your knife to come in
yeah that's interesting looks like urine
funnily enough do again urine yeah yeah
I went early because you uh you jabbed
it
I didn't jab it you did you jab did
anything I was scared it was gonna go
because I didn't shove it did you know
all right sir
so I thought I'm jamming it there's like
oh oh no I hope I don't ever do I not
huh see I thought you got it laughter I
didn't touch it
you jabbed in it and came away yeah
confused me so he started going down
already so I went out why this is all
happening a split second then then I
thought oh it's got to be now now jab it
so now you're thinking I'll go for it
yeah oh then it goes ours cool oh man
Oh wicked and now you stabbing it
stopped on the war won't do that it
looks like her likes no sense it looks
like a pea chandelier yeah that was
amazing especially show his bladders
burst I love that ha ha what I thought
that video was lovely
it was pretty wasn't it yeah all the pee
coming down lots of urine it was nice to
see the what a disc out as a the balloon
was spinning I think if if it wasn't
spinning I'll just come down a glob and
the air would get under it that way well
be sure to follow us on Twitter buy a
t-shirt buy a shirt as you can see that
one looks really nice yeah trust me I've
seen it and subscribe to the channel
because of slow-mo and stuff we love it
what's the douchiest where you can speak
like the right what you're doing but
really dishes okay
well tie this drill here bit taken I'm
doing it's pretty good I mean it's not
gonna move that worried about it
mile over it pretty good at this sort of
thing the best part about that was the
face you made before you start oh that's
it I'm a method actor yeah you like what
I'm doing
yeah what is Northern well is what I'm
doing I chose one your budget